number two from the daily wire says in
the past week the montana house
judiciary committee passed a bill which
would create the save women's sports act
an act that would bar biological boys
from teams or in sports designated for
women or girls
by passing the bill the committee set up
a floor hearing in the montana house the
sponsor of house bill 112
uh told the montana free press that he
wanted to protect the 1972 title ix
permitting biological boys to compete
against biology girls would be just
wrong he said
so they're passing this bill the reason
i'm reading this story is that
you know this is exactly what states
have to do um
you know it's what been one of my themes
over the last week is
let's let's let's localize our focus
as we have sometimes neglected to do as
conservatives
um and this is one area here now i also
wanted to as we were talking about
because we know the executive order from
biden as we as we're talking about
putting boys into girls sports or into
girl locker rooms
just to demonstrate just the
demonstration
you probably don't need a demonstration
but i'll give it to you anyway because
it's good to have it's good to have the
numbers just in front of you
so to demonstrate why it's insane to
allow
males to compete against girls and
sports and why you need bills like the
one they're passing in montana
um let's go to kind of a famous example
of boys competing against girls that's
in connecticut where you had
uh andrea yearwood and terry miller
those are both males and i think now
they've graduated but for a couple of
years you know they they
both guys and they uh but they they
identified as as girls and they started
running against girls in track and field
okay so here are the results from the
2019
connecticut state championships okay for
for the girls this is the 55 meter dash
um terry miller and andrea yearwood
for the state championships they both
came in first and second again in the
girls meet
they came in first and second as boys
terry miller was was first uh he had a
6.95 that was his time
andrea yearwood had 7.01
uh and then third quote unquote third
place which is
chelsea mitchell who really was first
place because she's the she is the
she she was the best sprint best the
best female sprinter in the state
in high school was chelsea mitchell but
she came in third place and she had a
7.23
which is significantly behind a 6.95 in
a sprint you know that's
might as well be an eternity okay now
keep those times in mind
you go over to the same year 2019 the
men's
varsity 55 meter dash now this is the
field that miller and yearwood
should have been competing against and
miller came in
in first place against the girls at 6.95
first place for the men's was 6.51
7th place was 6.63
so this is a guy who wouldn't even place
he wouldn't even make it on the track
he probably won't even qualify for the
finals against
the men with his times but against the
girls
he dominates this is a mediocre at best
male athlete male runner who against
females
dominates but if you look at the other
it's it's even more pronounced
like the 300 meter dash terry miller had
a 40.13
enough to beat second place was an
actual girl one second behind again one
second
and a dash is is a lot um but against
men
the number one time was 35.11
12 was 37.65 again
wouldn't have even made it on the track
with those times
so you you just you cannot look at that
and deny
the biological first of all the
biological difference between between
men and women
and also the fact that just the simple
fact of being
a guy affords you enormous inherent
advantages
that are very very difficult for a woman
to overcome
that a mediocre male athlete or even a
bad
male athlete could just waltz into a
women's sport and take over
casually without even having to work
that hard well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt well show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content